[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
convicted killer scott peterson is one
step closer to getting his new day in
court the hearing to determine if he
gets a noon trial in the murders of his
wife lacey and their unborn son all we
are trying to do is get it the truth and
one of our kelly's former manager says
employees were docked big pay for minor
offenses the singer facing sex
trafficking charges in federal court
what these
really these girls and boys experienced
was incredibly traumatic plus is robert
durst unraveling under a grueling
cross-examination
will the jury believe why durst says he
didn't call the police after finding his
best friend shot dead i did what i did
when i did what i felt i needed to do
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin convicted wife killer scott
peterson was back in court this week to
discuss scheduling for a hearing that
could determine whether he gets a new
trial law on crime's angel levy tells us
what happened
scott peterson is a little closer to
getting a hearing that will determine
whether or not he gets a new trial in
the murders of his wife lacey and their
unborn son connor
scott peterson's attorneys and
sister-in-law janie left the courthouse
without a date for that evidentiary
hearing but they appeared confident
nonetheless
we believe
very strongly that the evidentiary
hearing is going to prove what we've
said all along that scott peterson did
not get a fair trial the unresolved
question did juror rachelle neese
intentionally lie during jury selection
and on her questionnaire about being
involved in court proceedings
information unearthed by peterson's
attorneys and prosecutors show that
niece had been the victim of domestic
violence while she was pregnant and she
was once the subject of a restraining
order issued against her then
boyfriend's ex things she did not
disclose
niece has stated in court documents she
didn't consider herself the victim of a
crime peterson's lawyers say she
couldn't have been impartial
every defendant has a right to 12
independent
fair unbiased jurors but in a recent
court filing prosecutors wrote that
peterson's claims quote represent a
perfect example of what began as a
fishing expedition by a litigant who
lost at trial and they referred to his
claims as quote a witch hunt i think the
stanislaus county da's office using the
term witch hunt is a little ironic
given the fact that they put on a
16-year witch hunt against scott
peterson meanwhile one of nisa's fellow
jurors maintains her belief in
peterson's guilt did not taint
deliberations
being a woman and a mother
why would that opinion not be a strong
opinion she didn't in any way
influence anyone with her her position
the next hearing in peterson's case is
scheduled for september 22nd at that
time the judge said she will set a date
for that evidentiary hearing which could
last as long as two weeks judge ann
christine mizullo said she does not want
to hold that hearing in december that is
the month that lacey disappeared for law
and crime daily i'm angenette levy
thanks angeanette joining us today is
criminal defense attorney mike corobotix
and terry austin mike the prosecution is
claiming this is a phishing expedition
by the defense do you agree or is there
merit in arguing for a new trial
i believe there's merit in arguing for a
new trial i think any time a juror
profits
from their job as a juror writes a book
things of those name of that nature it
causes a major problem
in the case and it shows that they may
have not been fully straightforward when
they went through their voir dear or the
questioning by the council i think they
should pass a law that you're not
allowed to profit
and write books if you're a part of a
juror i think that would really stop
this problem and it's not a wish
witch-hunt or a fishing expedition yeah
it makes sense i could see that
definitely maybe weeding out a lot of
these problems terry what kind of
testimony and evidence do you expect to
be brought into this case if there is a
hearing could niece's book would the
other jurors be used as evidence
absolutely brian we will definitely hear
from these herself obviously but we
might hear from the other jurors as well
particularly those who helped with the
writing of this book we might also hear
from her mother and her ex-boyfriend
because we know they have information as
well particularly as relates to whether
or not there was a restraining order so
i think we might see them as witnesses
and even if that book is not admitted
into evidence and it'll probably be
difficult to establish a foundation and
it's here say et cetera you better
believe that the defense is going to be
using the information in that book to
determine whether or not there was any
mystery uh conduct there so we'll see
what happens yeah it's a lot of
different levels whether or not she was
unbiased and whether or not that might
have affected other jurors definitely
going to be interesting i think it's
going to be a two-week hearing as the
judge is anticipating so we'll
definitely continue that coverage as it
continues thank you
turning now to more top legal news a
federal appeals court is upholding the
death sentence for the charleston church
shooter
dylan roof was sentenced to death for
the june 2015 mass shooting at historic
black church roof killed nine
church-goers taking part in a bible
study in 2017 a south carolina jury
found roof guilty of 33 charges
including murder and hate crimes roof
appealed claiming he was not competent
to stand in trial and laws were not
properly applied to his case but a
three-judge panel is now ruling that
roof slaughtered the victims while they
welcomed him into their bible study
quote he used the internet to plan his
attack and using his crimes as a
catalyst intended to format racial
division and strife across america
and in california a grand jury indicted
68 year old ron jeremy on more than 30
counts of sexual assault the former
adult film star is charged for allegedly
abusing 21 women over a 23-year span
this includes the time he allegedly
raped a 19 year old girl at a photo
shoot the victims range from 15 to 51
years old and the investigation remains
to be ongoing jeremy plead not guilty to
all counts including forcible rape and
sexual battery
now to a shocking turn of events in the
colorado case of missing mom suzanne
morpheus an unidentified male dna linked
to three sexual assaults in two states
was found in her car suzanne morphy's
husband is now accused of murder but
during a pre-trial hearing a colorado
bureau of investigation agent confirmed
the match during cross-examination by
morpheus defense the dna turned up on
the glove box of suzanne morphy's car
the agent revealed the sample match in a
national database to sexual assault
cases in chicago illinois phoenix in
temp arizona a judge is expected to rule
at a later date if there's enough
evidence for barry morphy to stand trial
still ahead on law and crime daily are
kelly's alleged abuse is it isn't it
just the women his former employees now
speaking out but first the newly
released videos in the death of a 13
year old apparently killed by a
classmate who was seen running away from
the crime scene and why would a team
film himself in the back of a cop car
the evidence ahead
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live one
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back florida prosecutors have
released the selfie videos of a teen
accused of stabbing another teen to
death then taking a video in the back of
a cop car
aiden fuchi is accused of murdering
schoolmate 13-year-old tristan bailey
investigators say bailey was stabbed 114
times in newly released surveillance
videos fuchi and bailey are seen walking
together shortly before her death who
say fuchi has seen about an hour running
away by himself
in another video fuchi is in the back of
a police vehicle recording a selfie he's
awaiting trial for first degree murder
now to day seven of r kelly's trial
continuing with one of r kelly's former
employees taking the stand against him
tom arnold r kelly's road manager from
2006 to 2011 testified about what it was
like working for r kelly all those years
arnold testified sometimes appearing
shaky and nervous about the 20 plus
people who worked for r kelly including
security guards bus drivers audio
engineers and others and how this
network of employees including him had
pieces of paper with r kelly's number on
it that they would hand to girls at r
kelly's request
arnold also testified he had r kelly's
phone and would answer it for him he
identified some of the women art kelly
would have at his house and detail the
layout of the olympia field illinois
home and the fact that even when they
weren't on tour with three to six buses
that one would stay on the property and
r kelly and females would often stay
inside arnold continued by describing
working for our kelly the doctor pay for
minor infractions the rules about
leaving a room if a girl was in it or
that the girls would need permission to
leave the studio he also described that
that he quit when r kelly got mad he
booked a male tour guide for a vip tour
of disney world and his pay was docked
that week
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney mike corvonix and terry austin
terry when i listen to arnold's
testimony it screams rico like the
prosecution is setting up to connect the
dots do you see that too and how will
they do that
i definitely see that tom arnold is the
perfect witness for this rico allegation
he's a 12th witness on the stand but he
was the one who is able to put this
whole racketeering case together by
establishing this enterprise and the
enterprise here in kelly's case is all
of his employees the managers the
bodyguards the drivers of the cars and
as you said he
testified that all of them had telephone
number for kelly and that they were
instructed to give out the telephone
number to various girls and women and so
that's part of luring these women in and
getting them to participate in this
sexual ring and he was very important in
that regard and he also said that he
wasn't able to look at female employees
none of the other or rather female
guests none of the employees were able
to do that and he solidified the fact
that these women had to
act in a certain way so he was great for
the ricoh charge now mike let's play a
little devil's advocate cause you and i
make a living off of proving prosecutors
wrong is having your friend pass out
your number the beginning of rico
charges because if it is you should stop
handing out mine
well i i just hold on here's brian's
number uh but brian seriously what what
they
are doing i think it's very dangerous
because
whatever kelly did in the privacy of his
own time these people were not hired
specifically to do that unless they
could prove they were these people had
real jobs and he was a major corporation
i do think sometimes federal prosecutors
use the rico statute which only probable
cause to charge not proof beyond a
reasonable doubt because once you have a
ricoh case it really broadens the
hearsay rules of evidence and things
that maybe double here say
triple here say are admissible
if it's furtherance of the ricoh so i
think that's another strategy they use
and we're sort of seeing that in the
durst case although that's not a rico
case but that kind of hearsay comes in
interesting to see how that'll play out
not just for the trial but any potential
appeals that might come up afterwards
thank you both coming up on law and
crime daily would susan berman talk to
investigators about her best friend what
robert durst has to say
plus the woman testifying against r
kelly we speak with a psychologist about
the trauma of taking the stand and
what's next for them after this trial
stay with us
[Music]
we're back one by one women are taking
the stand against r kelly alleging
decades of abuse rape and forced
abortions terry austin spoke with a
clinical psychologist about what these
women can do now that they're out of his
alleged control
brian i spoke with dr catherine coleman
about what she believes it will take for
these women to heal both psychologically
and emotionally
one thing that's really important for
these victims to keep in mind is that
this was not their fault um an abuser
will make it seem like the victims were
at fault here that they were groupies
that they wanted this that it was
consensual
that there was some bigger purpose that
they were doing this for um
and they're going to ask themselves a
lot of the same questions that we're
being asked of why did they continue to
stay despite all of this and it's going
to be really important for them to have
that education about you know the cycle
of abuse and what that looks like and
truly you know what these really these
girls and boys experienced was
incredibly traumatic and so
it's going to be important for them to
recognize they're not at fault
and to seek some help so that they can
you know go on to live a
robust and meaningful life i've seen
comments that people are blaming even
the parents what can a parent do to sort
of avoid this to happening to one of
their children
i mean it's interesting that you bring
that up um i was listening to a podcast
about this the other day um specifically
about uh a family member of one of the
girls
who uh you know somebody brought it up
to them that r kelly was abusing
their family member and they didn't want
to believe it at first i think you know
for most people we tend to believe that
people are good and that they have you
know pure hearts so that they're willing
to help
you know family members may have seen r
kelly as this person that was going to
pull their family out of poverty you
know remember a lot of these um a lot of
these victims nearly all were people of
color um many came from low social
economic status households and this was
their family's ticket um to
to success and some freedom and to some
financial freedom so this is this was a
huge deal for them and so why would you
want to believe that something so
horrendous
was happening to your family member
that's an excellent point so finally i'm
thinking about all of this testimony
that's coming in about r kelly's
behavior do you think that he
experienced in the past some
psychological trauma or some
psychological issues that he's dealing
with typically what you'll see with
people who commit this type of abuse is
that there's something in their past
right because something had to make them
think
to even do this in the first place and
so you have to wonder where that came
from um was that past abuse gosh i've
never seen a movie that forced people to
eat pc so you do wonder where that comes
from um these are pretty significant
paraphilias and fetishes um that's
beyond you know dominant submissive type
of consensual relationships that you'll
sometimes see in adults so it's it's
really quite sickening and so it's
difficult to fathom that there is not
something there
exactly well thank you so much dr
catherine coleman we appreciate your
being here and we can't wait until
you're on again next time on law and
crime anytime
thank you terry r kelly's trial will be
dark on friday and is set to resume
monday
when we come back robert durst is back
on the stand in california what the real
estate air has to say about his now dead
best friend susan berman was she willing
to go to authorities the testimony next
[Music]
welcome back we're looking to california
where robert durst has been under a
grueling cross-examination for more than
40 hours
robert durst is on trial for the murder
of his best friend susan berman durst
now admits to discovering susan's body
in her benedict canyon home and says he
quickly fled the scene instead of
calling the police durst sent the
infamous cadaver note in hopes that it
would lead authorities to her body in an
intense line of questioning during
cross-examination durst claims that he
didn't call the police when finding
susan's body because the phone didn't
work that quickly unraveled in the hands
of john lewin
your intention was to call 9-1-1 right
at that time correct so the only reason
that you did not call 9-1-1 is the phone
did not work correct
so why didn't you immediately run next
door
to a neighboring house
and try to get
help i didn't
i didn't ask you what you did mr durst
we know what you did i asked you why you
did not do that
do you have an explanation
i keep having to come up with these
explanations
i did what i did when i did what i felt
i needed to do
shocking admissions in front of the jury
but after they left the courtroom for a
break the judge expressed his need to
wrap up durst's testimony telling the
prosecutor why he thinks lewin has more
than adequately questioned derse on
cross
i would think the following is true
first of all
the defendant's testimony was was not
credible
secondly
on day one it appeared that
you
really effectively uh destroyed any
possible credibility of this witness
on day three
i believe by day three i think you had
very very serious i would even say
profound
admissions day four day five you're
going through each of his statements to
prove that every
statement is false
every statement he has made it seems
you're addressing and you're right i
think at some point there's a limit it
doesn't seem there's any further purpose
it seems additional questioning would be
an undue consumption of time
now durst is admitting that his best
friend was keen to telling stories and
volunteering information but durst is
rebutting the prosecution's theory of
the case arguing susan wouldn't have
been found credible if questioned by new
york prosecutors about the disappearance
of his wife kathy
i might be charged with murder by janine
pirro
but i don't think susan would have had
whatever susan said
had anything to do with it
because if janine pirro had an
investigator
actually interview susan
he would conclude that susan's fault
that it wouldn't really matter whether
susan was quote full of
you would be a
creak because your situation would be
that your best friend is telling
investigators you murdered your wife and
she covered it up correct that's the
following question
mike i get it lewin wants to prove that
every word every syllable every breath
out of dirt's mouth is a lie but at some
point we get it durst is a liar is it
time for lewin to move on
it is i mean it's just a repetition and
i think he's got a lot to work with but
you know the jury wants to hear it in a
neater way they want to hear the facts
then they want to hear you comment and
put the facts together based on your
argument i think they're doing a lot on
this cross of both of those things and
it's going to get lost on the jury i
think the judge may be doing him a favor
yeah now terry the defense may or may
not put on another witness i've heard
maybe an asperger's expert than rest do
you think the prosecution needs to at
this point or will put on a rebuttal
case
well actually even though loon has gone
ad nauseum with his
questioning of this witness
we do think that there should be a rebut
at least i think there should be a
rebuttal i definitely think that he
should call and he's indicated as much
they've agreed that
andrew jarecki will come on by video as
a rebuttal witness and i think that's
extremely important and it's important
because
we know that durst has relied repeatedly
on saying that directly was the one who
told him to say all of these statements
and so i think it's important that we
call jarecki and we might also see
douglas durst come back up on the stand
to rebut some of the things that durst
has said so i definitely think that
lewin is going to take this opportunity
to do more of his case and maybe show
where there were more lies by durst and
you know we know lauren he's not going
to rest right here if the law allows him
to have additional speaking time and i
think he'll come up and frankly i think
in these instances he should
hey i think lewin has won already i
would be afraid of someone in the jury
catching covenant and maybe a mistrial
because of that but that's just me
thank you for joining us here at law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you